well one of the fundamental things that
humans and animals do is find their way
around the world so they to do that they
need to know where they are and they
need to know where other things are and
they need to know the relationship
between these places and the way the
brain does that is it represents places
where you are now and and it represents
distances and directions and so over the
years what we've been able to establish
is which parts of the brain do this
particularly a part of the brain called
the hippocampus and the related areas
and especially one of them the internal
cortex and what types of cells that are
there which represent these different
kinds of spatial information and we know
that there are cells representing places
so when you're in the familiar
environment different cells represent
different locations in environment we
know there are cells which represent
directions so that when you're looking
in a particular direction or moving in a
particular direction there are cells
which tell the rest of the brain that
and then we also know there are cells
which appear to tell the distances that
are moved in particular directions and
if you put all these together what that
provides you with is something we call a
cognitive map which is a framework for
identifying where you are where other
things are in environment and how to get
from one place